yeah let's go
hello I'm gonna put you guys on speaker
I'm actually super not particular or
fancy so I ensure a good night's sleep
because I leave it all on the field the
18 hours that I'm awake and so I'm so
unconscious by the time it's time to go
to sleep that I can fall asleep on nails
in an Iraqi prison the question should
be do we have a good understanding of
where the consumer that we're trying to
reach is spending their time and
attention and do we understand how to
create the words sounds videos and
pictures that would influence them to do
what we want them to do on and in those
places
how do you see the concepts of crushing
it applying intrapreneurs at a company
as opposed to entrepreneurs you know
intrapreneurs are able to if they're in
the right corporations they'll be able
to produce content that would allow
their seniority leaders to see some of
their thoughts that maybe they wouldn't
hear in a meeting or through the
serendipity of crossing them in the
halls or a business environment and so
they're able to share their opinions
thoughts and ideas in a manner that
would allow people to consume it aka a
medium post or LinkedIn post that they
would post has the serendipitous
opportunity or strategic media planned
opportunity for their boss's boss boss
to read and if her idea was phenomenal
that may lead to an opportunity within
that organization my words
that was awesome they loved it
do you have context if that person's
asking how they can separate themselves
from their company because they own that
company
yeah donar by being disciplined and
understanding that your company isn't
you and you aren't your company that's a
mindset strategy you you know without a
healthy separation of understanding that
you can really lead to a detrimental
mindset outside of my two grandfathers
who I never got to know which would
easily be the answer we would talk about
just the history of our family their
parents and grandparents that would just
be interesting to me no question it
would be Randy the Macho Man Savage and
no I'm super sad that I wasn't able to
get to a place right I met him and got
to have a conversation he was such a
great storyteller and like my favorite
wrestler and I think we would have
talked about like early wrestling
history his baseball career and why I
think a lot of my content is inspired by
him
company with 11 employees do at home
both radio and newspaper had still work
for party industry what was the first
part I heard the 11 employees but not
the rest I think they work I think
everything works I think they're grossly
overpriced if you spend a thousand
dollars on yellow pages and you get one
customer from it it worked but it cost
you a thousand dollars you know to me
that same thousand gets you 4 customers
on Facebook even when you suck at it so
the answer is no by the way it's asked
the answer is yes because I'm trying to
be nuanced here and educate people on
LinkedIn and obviously my blog who's
watching right now
so the answer is sure but I think it's
grossly overpriced at that same money
spent on Google on Facebook and and
influencers and podcasting would go much
further
how do you say no to different
opportunities and focus on carnival in a
project poorly I have big eyes and big
ambitions and I'm very curious and so I
struggle with this I've gotten better
over time and that's because I've
learned that it's not in my best
interest and so I wouldn't suppress it
completely because that's what keeps you
creative and entrepreneurial but I think
it's just an evolution of trying your
best and always remembering what the
what the prize is probably Holograms you
know I can see that and and I'm excited
about being in hologram form and and
marketing that way and then probably
three things that I've never even
thought of in a million years inventions
that don't even exist yet I never ever
ever ever thought about self-driving
cars until I first heard about it I
never thought about augmented reality
and how people would see fake characters
in my content until I heard about it I
never thought about virtual reality
until I heard about it I never thought
about having a cell phone when cell
phones didn't exist so things that don't
exist
by disproportionately over-communicating
and on the value props that that
person's looking for clear and concise
communications in in a deck or verbal
form that that are scratching the needs
of that customer what's that
what's the best wine you've ever had
19:47 shovel c h-e-b al Blanc BL a and C
my god I mean I mean I mean I this is
not me to answer this what's that
everything like I it's it's it's a I I
don't even want to disrespect this how
want you'd answer it I don't even want
to disrespect you X Y Z format you know
who asked this question by giving a
half-assed answer meaning it's so by
narrowly broken to me that I would I
need a literally need to like make a
45-minute documentary to answer that
question
there's no 5 to 7 to 15 sentences that
could even begin to allow me to tackle
it it's broken at its core
that way or McDonough McDonald's
do you ever turn off social media you
ever take a break yeah when I go on
vacation on some weekends during
check-ins tons of time
[Music]
how did you get your start in investing
what tools of platform did you use and
how did you broaden your understanding
of the stock market I don't know
anything about the stock market so let
me start there and when I came to
investing I became friendly with some of
the early employees of Twitter which
then allowed me to buy his shares and
that's how it started it was just
personal relationships that led to an
opportunity to acquire some equity and
then from there once I was a Twitter
stock holder and Twitter exploded that
year other companies started coming to
me and I learned on the fly
of what it meant to buy from employees
when it meant to invest in a Series A or
B or or C drowned it was a it was a
learning by app you know baptized by
fire or whatever you know
so her piece from India says afters you
got an MBA he went to a job but then he
left that job in seven months because he
wasn't learning anything and the growth
was slow and now he can't find a new job
because she didn't stay at that job for
one year and he's been thinking about
calling and kinking over his father's
business but this is bad and now he's
afraid should I do that and what if it
fails and I won't be able to get a job
after that either because I haven't
completed that second fight I only laugh
at a job there's too many other jobs
that don't give a [ __ ] about those two
failures so he should go in to his dad's
business ASAP and and there will be
hundreds of people that are willing to
hire him with those two strikes on his
resume my intuition is that he didn't
try to go to enough places I don't think
every job in the world
viewed him not working somewhere for a
year as a scarlet letter that's a great
question
somebody who brings warmth and and value
to somebody with no expectation in
return
what do you recommend for someone who is
almost 24 and has a business and
marketing degree but no know what they
want to do for their career do something
what companies are streaming out do you
currently have that I have no idea I'm
so closed to businesses right now like
Phil Toronto is filtering that stuff for
me but I mean tons I get hundreds of
emails a day but I literally pay them no
mind I'm totally checked out of
investing right now
what comes after social media I have no
idea I would really appreciate any
knowledge of how to start your first
business with a really cool logo at its
core but I'll have five years of
experience get somebody to give you
money that is in a bank or start selling
[ __ ] from the beginning and make profit
from the beginning and be patient
raising capital is only one highly /
popular way to start a business
you always say you have time but what
were you doing at 24 I was working 15
hours a day in a liquor store in New
Jersey making $47,000 a year in the
process of building a huge business for
my parents
working seven days a week doing zero
things socially when it comes to leading
people not a lot actually I love it I
think I'm real natural leader because I
have zero expectations of others uh
firing I would say firing
which marketing channel would be the
best to consider in 2018 for the b2b
sector combination of Facebook and
LinkedIn and Google search Google search
and Google pre-roll YouTube pre-roll
videos based on Google search queries
ETF I don't I don't think I don't do
that
I'm gonna fill I want this whole thing
thump spitting the whole thing what's up
YouTube
what do you look for instinctively when
you are researching your clients
I know v6 my clients where do you go
when you feel stuck within my own head
that's the one thing you know now that
you didn't when you were younger got a
lot I mean everything like I believe an
experience tremendously
what really stands out
it's really funny how similar I am to
when I was a kid it's just advanced
version
I think everything man I just did gap
anything I would just put everything
it's the right answer thank
how would you suggest older more
well-connected experts and later career
individuals leverage LinkedIn and new
tools to launch more successful by
sharing their wisdom and knowledge in
written or video form at scale for free
aka right a lot of things like what did
you learn when you were older that you
didn't know when you were young kind of
pieces I would start focusing on the New
York Knicks and I'm extremely happy
you always feel ready are you ever
nervous always still ready
how do I get more clients my consulting
company what small steps can I take
today for the magma start producing
content on LinkedIn and Facebook and
allow the content to be your lead gem to
your business leads
is it good to help people even but we
know they don't deserve it
yes you know you don't help people based
on them you help people based on you
giving us selfish
[Music]
ladies are having your team work remote
or having them all in the same office
I'm an all in the same office kind of
guy because I like the touchy-feely and
human interaction but I think remote
works if you look at the 37signals
founders they love that and others I
don't think it's a right or wrong I
think it's a very personal kind of thing
Wow pretty cool yet Tyler recorded
everything I'm gonna make a video just
of the whole thing people watching this
video which was your favorite question
and answer thanks for watching
[Music]